obviously your characters are extremely
personal to you I just wanted to know
that out of theon greyjoy and Jaime
Lannister which would you be most proud
to have as a son great question I think
maybe bran would be a good answer I
don't know it depends on what kind of
father I was there there's a lot of
father-son stuff in the books which you
know it's something that I like people
to think about there's a lot of
mother-daughter stuff in the books too
of course
that is one thing I wish I could do more
of it I didn't do enough of in Game of
Thrones before I ripped us starts apart
I would have liked to have shown more
scenes with a cat actually interacting
with her her two daughters yeah I mean
there are scenes of her interacting with
the with the boys but not so much the
girls yeah right and stuff like that and
cat is very busy running her castle
absolutely and I mean there is the the
the scene in in the first season where
you you have Sophie or you know you're
breaking hair and she's talking about
what a dreamboat saw four years
marry him right now and right then of
course that's it
that's not actually in the book laughs
no no those are always fun scenes see
that's one of the things I wish and I
have told David Mann this from the
beginning I wish we had more hours
because we we have ten hours but like
Boardwalk Empire is 12 and and Treme had
like 13 and and you know at some of
these other HBO shows have slightly
longer seasons than us we're hitting all
the high spots but weed there are little
personal scenes like that one that I
think we could have more of including
some scenes from the books that deepen
the characters in their relationship and
if we had more time we could do it but
of course time is money and our the show
is already very expensive and David and
Dan and made it clear that their heads
would explode if they had to do three
more episodes this season I don't know
how those guys are surviving it anyway
my job is easy compared to theirs but in
reply to a question Jaime Lannister
we've seen with bran and also the Red
Queen like the power of the Lord of
Light and also the old gods but is there
a particular reason why we haven't heard
from the seven yet I don't I'm not sure
what you mean by heard from you know a
postcard a telegram
email I don't attend none of these gods
have been on stage
I mean people believe in them just as
people believe in the seven but I I
don't intend to ever actually bring a
God on stage and have him interacting
with people I'm not sure any of the gods
and Westeros are real I'm not sure that
any of the gods in real world are real
I'm I'm a doubter in that sense which is
not to undermine not to say that the
people will believe in him don't don't
believe in them I mean in in the books I
think the the seven can be seen most
strongly in some of the Davos chapters
you know I recall the the this section
where Davos lives through the Battle of
Blackwater and it's found clutching this
rock and and is saved he really does
feel that he mother he had a vision of
the mother and she appealed peered to
him and he feels that the seven are
instructing him to kill Melisandre so
his faith in the seven is driving some
of his his beliefs and Catelyn in the
book also has a hesitating religious
faith in the face at seven yeah yeah
but other than that you know it works on
a on a more i don'ti Matic and symbolic
function and a literal one my question
is about considering how many projects
you have going you've got the calendars
you've got the books the show writing
the actual you know finishing the books
how do you quarantine your writing time
do you just have months where you you go
home and you shut yourself off or is it
how do you actually find the time along
with everything that comes along with
having a wildly successful series well
it's it's I don't write when I travel
and I know some people some of my fans
are very upset about that and think I
should but you know believe me I've
tried
I you know back in the 90s and you
the 80s when I would take a laptop that
they were new then and kind of heavy it
was like a briefcase but I would take
them on trips when I was going to Europe
or something like that and I would try
to write in my hotel room or try to
write on the plane and they would be
very frustrating I'm a creature of habit
I need I can only write I don't want to
be disturbed I tell people you know
don't don't bother me don't put through
any phone calls nobody come in here
leave me alone all day that's when I
write so I don't write when I travel but
when at home I work almost every day now
do I write fiction almost every day well
I tried to but sometimes life conspires
against that - there's you know that
there's a lot of good stuff about the
level of success I've had but it also
brings with it certain consequences and
a tremendous amount of mail and email
and business stuff
I've been hiring assistants to try to
take some of that off my shoulders but
it's not something I'm getting used to
I'm still still learning how to delegate
stuff and I do think frankly to be
honest with you guys I have to learn to
say no more particularly when this thing
really started burgeoning even before
the show I mean the last few years when
I was hitting the bestseller lists very
high I started getting a lot of
invitations to other projects and a lot
of invitations to travel and I try to
keep my word and keep my promise when I
give a commitment I go through with it
and I said yes to a lot of things that
sounded like fun whether it's a
convention or a book tour or interviews
and other projects I love doing other
projects I love editing books I love
writing short stories I have other
stories that I want to tell her I'm not
nice and fire so I said yes to a lot of
things and then
little few years into it I was saying
why did I say yes to all these things I
have to learn to say to say no
occasionally here and I've joked about
that on mind on my blog I talk about all
the monkeys on my back but I have would
not have felt right canceling those
obligations once I had taken that on I I
don't do that so I've been doing them
but one by one I've been getting the
monkeys off my back in there there are
much fewer monkeys it's not the big one
of course is winds of winter and that's
King Kong and my obligation is to show
we're also up there and that's son of
Kong but the other monkeys are
relatively small or dead so I'm doing
the best I can as well I can say the
time for one more I didn't get one more
question from down here so make it the
best one okay yeah George people have
such a sense of ownership of your work
to the point where if they see you're
not working on them they get really
angry and I think we've all seen some
pretty disgusting things that have been
said on the internet about that now
personally I think those people can go
[ __ ] themselves
but do you just put that out of your
mind when you're writing or has it
affected you in some way and do you
think sometimes you know maybe I maybe I
should be writing more you know I I
always think well always is too big a
word but I frequently think I should be
writing more but then again I always
have you know I mean this is one things
that I think some of the people were
critical of me don't don't seem to
understand them at every time as I say
it is that I've always been a slow
writer
it's just nobody was aware of it because
they weren't waiting on me but
yeah you know I I wrote my first four
novels without a contract you know which
is very unusual I mean mostly in in in
the publishing business you do you do a
sample chapter two and then you do an
outline at arrested a book and your
agents in surround the publishers and
then you get a contract with a deadline
I didn't want to do that because I
didn't want the deadlines
I knew that would I don't like deadlines
so I wrote entire novels dying at a
light and fever dream and so forth
nobody even knew I was working on those
novels I just sat all by myself I wrote
it and it was completely done I sent it
to my agent and said there it is here's
a novel sell it and they did ideally
that would be to where I would work on
this too but of course you can't do that
with a what a series of any any sorts
well that there are days even when I
write 10 pages that I wish I'd written
more oh damn I why I ran out of steam I
should have written 12 pages but not
that I write 10 pages off in a day
that's a lot of work but you pressure
George oh yeah constant I do find
pressure and and you know I think all
writers have have or well maybe not all
many writers have deep insecurities I
don't know somehow it's something that
feeds the writerly personality and I
suspect actors have this too you know
yet you get a hundred good reviews and
you get one bad review and that's bad
one just obsesses you're right that's
why I don't read them yeah you know read
your reviews no no no because I think
it's it is that classic thing if you
Reba leave the goods you've got to
believe the bad you know sir mmm-hmm I
don't read them so I don't know what's
that did I answer the question I bet
I've lost him right there Billy you you
have to try to put that stuff aside and
when the work is going well I do put
that stuff aside you know I shut myself
off from
my office and I forget that everything
exists that the my publishers are
waiting for the book or the fans are
waiting for the book I forget about the
show I'm just in Westeros I mean I'm
with some particular character with REO
or brand or Sansa and I'm in a scene and
I'm wrestling with the words okay what
what do they say next how do I say that
how do I describe what's happening how
do I make it vivid and evocative and you
know I beat my head against a sentence
and nothing else enters that it's just
me in that sentence wrestling in in the
pit at that point you know afterwards
when I shut off the computer for today
and and go over maybe other things enter
my mind but not that I can't ever be
distracted from from that well I think
we're all prepared for you to take as
much time as you need to because we know
that when the book comes it will be
absolutely perfect and amazing and no
one will die right yeah ladies and
gentlemen Michelle Fairley george RR
martin